so on a scale of one to ten how ready
are you like you have the nursery do you
have everything prepared
i'm here in the nursery now it's not
finished i actually just put this uh
crib together the other day um but
lauren's gonna try to finish it up in
the next couple weeks because the baby's
gonna be here into may
and you said you're having a baby boy
right yeah baby boy i prayed so hard for
a boy
lauren wants a girl as well so i'm gonna
pray hard for a girl
second time around do you have a name
picked out
we do um we aren't 100
settled in on anything at this point but
we have narrowed it down to a couple
um which were you know pumped about one
of the names i threw out that got shut
down
incredibly fast was rambo rambo
no you can't do that in my mind i
thought
you know what that sounds tough so
whenever he comes up
uh on the tee box and they're saying you
know now on the team
rambo lane it sounds like he's 100 gonna
hit the ball 400 yards
you know when you put it with your last
name it actually does sound kind of
badass
well it's not going to happen regardless
but one thing that's not up for debate
the release of chris's new single summer
job money
summer job money has such a great vibe
what inspired that song
um honestly great question i'm a huge
kenny chesney fan
i love summertime nostalgic throwback
kind of songs and he's the king of those
and i feel like this song summer job
money does
exactly what i want it to do and i
cannot wait for
people to hear it can't wait to play it
live as well